bonsoir à tous et merci de votre
attention incroyable inimaginable
hallucinant les mots font défaut pour
qualifier la très vaste
la très spectaculaire opération
terroriste mené aujourd'hui on va
d'abord revivre les événements le
pentagone bien sûr et surtout ses tours
immenses du world trade center percutées
de plein fouet par deux avions de ligne
détournés
on a cru d'abord un accident la panique
et l'incrédulité images commentées par
thierry curtet l'image est effroyable un
premier avion a déjà percuté la première
tour un deuxième appareil se présente
ils visent ils percutent l'autre tours
jumelles du world trade center
il est 9h 14 à new york le boeing n'a
pas dévié sa trajectoire d'un seul
maître transformer en kamikaze
il se crashe sur le symbole de la toute
puissance économique américaine les
prestigieuses twin towers de new york
quarante minutes plus tard à washington
un troisième avion s'écrase sur le
pentagone
le plus stratégique de tous les
bâtiments militaires américains puis un
quatrième appareil à 747 s'écrase en
pennsylvanie
ces quatre avions de ligne détournés
provenaient de trois villes différentes
et transportait 2 166 passagers à new
york
les deux avions transformé en missile
ont percuté les deux tours au moment de
l'arrivée au bureau des 50000 personnes
qui travaillait au world trade center
des dizaines d'employés font des signes
désespérés
d'autres vont choisir de se jeter par
les fenêtres
les deux bâtiments jumeaux mesure plus
de 400 mètres de haut mais les deux
tours véritable monument de new york ne
vont pas résisté bien longtemps
la première se brise par le milieu
bascule et s'effondre
la seconde quelques minutes plus tard
implose et s'écroule
chacun des deux bâtiments peser plus de
300 mille tonnes située au bord d'une
rivière d'un côté mais adossé au
quartier des affaires de wall street de
l'autre le maire de new york parle d'un
effroyable bilan sans annoncer le
moindre chiffre
l'aviation civile américaine décide de
fermer tous les aéroports des états unis
ou d'un avion civil est autorisé à voler
les trains doivent rester en gare les
frontières avec le canada et le mexique
sont bouclés et marchés financiers en
chute libre fermé
l'amérique est paralysé